that's not I know what intro whatever
let's just go with that okay so there's
one thing that I haven't been doing on
this channel very often that I know you
guys absolutely love but I'm just too
much for a wimp to do them too often but
now I'm doing them because then I know
they're loved
it's wimpy Carol plays you might have
already seen this game before it's
called Emily wants to play a lot of
youtubers have done it a while ago I
think we're supposed to be pretty scary
I never saw it though I don't really
know what it's about and all I know it's
it's supposed to be really scary
I've made a horror game in a while okay
so I'm kind of worried a head is so
close to the camera right now yeah hello
your pizza's here
why do I mean like a jump already but
that was creepy okay do I need to like
right-click things why would I want to
turn up for light that doesn't weigh it
it's very young pixely isn't it like do
I have to like oh no I don't have to
[ __ ] what is that ellaby what you want
about LMB LMP like what was that oh okay
right left mouse button okay I got you I
told you around play tourism such
planning so what's the point of this why
why do I have to go into their house why
can't I just go back to my job and be
like nope no no I don't I love horror
games but you know broken glass the
whole mirror is shattered as always
angry oh this is not shower care that's
all right then all right
spooky clown to scary clowns together
hello [ __ ] okay was it I think they want
to kill me
here these guys well whoever whoever
lived here like um
as always you just moved it because all
that stuff is still you know oh no no no
no no there's not meant to be that I
meant to turn it on but obviously can't
turn these on whatever oh oh okay
but didn't this door open for us what
was the point you're going in here
hey guys ain't confused can I open any
drawers okay why am i doing what is the
point of this I don't get it they have
so many boxes how much stuff do they
want Oh apples
bhaiyyaji keeps doctor away what is this
go ahead love those graphics
cool
there's like this one hour battery or
something would at that but this water
so shiny any note anything in the fridge
okay is it so scary this isn't bad
I'm not really progressing though I'm
just kind of don't look at her
winky face okay jealous boyfriend
message right there I don't like the
noises can I run can I run shift
yeah cool no freaking [ __ ] no I mean
sorry oh my god it was her why oh here
we go make it much better quality than
you guys okay I thought I can maybe put
a brightness up but yeah that's probably
cheating okay let's try and find out
what we're supposed to do here
oh okay so that was a checkpoint that's
cool ah we are such better graphics now
sorry didn't know that before I just
said ah this might not run so well and
my little crappy crappy Mac okay so
sorry but we're gonna have to go retro
because this channel is so professional
that's my computer cannot run with
really good graphics but you add a
little sneak peek into how they would
look my computer can handle it so that's
something you know that's okay it's
still scary Wow oh I like to choose
fears right okay so I'm guessing balls
we can do this don't try and go out the
front door think no no don't want to do
that or might wanna do so okay
so I'm guessing
the door is locked I come in I've got my
pizza where is the pizza nor here okay I
can run with the shift
I a duster terrain oh I do don't look at
how I want it
the lights on here now that's nice oh oh
hello
okay cool wait what the [ __ ] am I doing
there
they locked me up down down where life
is their basement
oh there's no the doctor here okay
mr. Marino ah I don't like this freaking
baby thing like it freaks me the [ __ ]
out okay down here by okay let's go
I so crapper this what am I supposed to
do you guys can I give up yet no I'm
gonna game playing for 12 minutes okay
what about this dog Oh have I been
through this door yet I can't see me
getting very far in this game can you
wimpy girl is oh oh the legs oh dear all
the lights are off like seriously why
okaywe just find things do things do all
the things like do what she wants you to
do just don't hold back I don't even
know what I'm saying but if I'm quiet
I'm scared so I need to talk to you guys
talk to me I keep breathing the room
okay so I know don't don't don't do
those noises with me don't its Gabi
okay um at least I had some friends in
the basement I can't even go in the
basement okay
they won't let me yeah we have to go
down okay should we go down there Oh
what's this no one will help us no one
can help us this house had a basement in
it I made a place for Emily down there
my husband hid the entrance so that
never one can ever find it
who's gonna mean this the time that I
cried because the gay but literally my
knees are shaking
it's not even on the graphics
am I just supposed to like no surely I'm
supposed to go into the basement aren't
I I'm not just supposed to wait here
something to happen remember when I
first start playing smells like I had
this it's not even finished long okay
all right little baby boo I'm coming to
see you I don't play with you okay let's
forget about the basement we don't want
to go there okay
where do we want to go I don't we just
want to go stop laughs all right come on
then like they always want us to go in
these tours have any of you played this
game before
only not I bet you've just watched
people play a haven't you don't tickle
don't you dare do the giggle thank you
Oh
what's this what is that have I got it
oh I'm going upside down wait wait that
one site okay what does that mean
what no where are you all right
hey hey hey I don't really know what to
do with you like if I walk past you you
gonna kill me
so where do I go what do I know I don't
can I just stand here and look in your
okay oh oh schizer that actually works
okay well for the the letter told me not
not to look at them again the hang of
this game guys the first like 15 minutes
of this video is just gonna be me
freaking out screaming every ten seconds
did I find everything in here then so
it's definitely nothing in the computers
oh they will never take my friends away
from me please
no is that little Emily with a little
friends like um oh [ __ ] where are you
where she oh hello
you're so tiny alright I'm feeling but
I'm doing something this is good good
progress see she's not that scary
especially not with my rubbish graphic
I'm so sorry
but it's okay we like retro here we're a
fan of retro games my target audience
sir
well my main audience are like a little
bit 18 to 25 you think you are up I take
care of my friends and make them pretty
smiley face don't turn around
pink yeah they've done that to me a lot
your friends love to play that game
thanks to you and you as well actually
Emily I'm guessing you're the guy on the
black oh hello I've missed these your
mother place
my psychiatrist says I should start
recording a log to help with my
depression he doesn't know it's all
about Emily I can't tell him anything
about that but I'll record myself anyway
maybe Emily I'm trying this up to your
mother's recordings mean you won't allow
me bloody hell children there is so
creepy though aren't they
we just wait but why are they because
they can't hurt you
well I mean this one can Oh clearly this
one count but you know normally little
kids they're nothing to be scared of but
they're really really scary in horror
games and films anyway stop talking
Yasmine all right turn back on the
lights not playing this game with you
mister and release actually I'm not
going in here mm way to joke for my
Lincoln but what about this one they
don't care about me they never loved me
is that her parents
the fire excited yes okay
thank you but doing things like I don't
know how but we're doing them know that
one
please Emily don't turn off the lights
oh there's a freaky little angel thing
down there he's scary they locked me up
down there
Oh where's that I said I'm here that's
the program oh one thing I know is I
definitely don't think I can go into the
base no clown man hmm
yes I'm always gonna annoy you because
I'm not I'm not running away from you I
know I know what to do now oh nice
I've just got to stand up to them show
them who's boss
I'm the boss my friends help me they
love me oh that's a climb an don't move
where are you okay then where'd it come
from what is the other like ah the
Skinner has gone from being absolutely
bloody terrifying to okay I can handle
you what's that come on join us we are
one that it's creepy yeah oh no don't do
that um thank you for the offer but I
think I'm a gay I just wanted to bring
you your pizza did you did not one like
why would anyone where is he
okay I think that's it for the if the
first playthrough over
Emily what's played if you think this is
interesting enough for me to play more
of let me know in the comments below I'm
kind of confused about what the outcome
of this is I hope there's a core
narrative it seems that there actually
is more of a narrative now that I kind
of understand it a bit more starting to
make sense anyway I hope you already
enjoyed this I know I hadn't done a
Wimpy girl plays in a long time so I
really hope it's made up for it and I
hope you enjoyed laughing at my screams
of Terror I love it everything bye
I have never played on an oculus rift
before so this is my first ever
opportunity and it's with the most
terrifying horror game ever so yeah I
cannot tell you how terrified I am right
now and because I can't even see you so
let's just play this game even though I
walk through the darkest Valley I will
fear no evil